The next type of partnerships might be joint business development,
joint promotion of complimentary products.
One might be the dominant player. The best example of this in the computer industry was Intel.
Now, historically, chips ended up to be inside the computer that the consumer never saw at all,
and in fact, the only name on the outside of the box was the manufacturer,
but Intel in 1980s changed that game.
They said what if we pay PC manufacturers to put the phrase Intel Inside on the outside of the box,
and what used to be just this unknown piece of silicone inside the computer
actually became a valuable brand for joint business development,
joint promotion by sharing advertising dollars and sales programs.